[音楽]
この写真見て頂けますか
私の息子といとこたちの写真です
このこれは可愛かったんですよ
将来どんな大人になるのかなって楽しみにしていた母でした
左端の
ちょっと地蔵様にも似ているのが私の子なんです
この子なん20年経って飲食店を任されて
やりがいを持って仕事を頑張っていました
その息子がある日
こうつぶやきました
うつ病かもしれない
私は冷静を装っていましたが
心の中は競っていて
えっ
仕事楽しいって言ってたじゃない
私前向きで元気なイメージでコーチングのインストラクターしているのにどうしたら
いいの
+をにしている息子よりも
自分の立場や世間体で頭がいっぱいでした
先ない母親ですよね
その後息子は仕事に行けなくなって引きこもりという状態になりました
大人の引きこもり
実は大勢いることをご存知ですか
仕事に行けなくて家族以外の人との交流もほとんどしないで過ごしている人たちです
私たちはそういう人が実際にどれぐらいいるのか
地元の方や学生さんにアンケート調査をしました
その結果
6.4%
15人に1人
大人の引きこもりの方がいると分かりました
年齢もさまざまで
15歳から
62歳までいらっしゃいました
そして日本だけじゃなく
世界中に
清盛の人はいます
これは徐々に問題になってきています
引きこもりの人への主なサポートは
3つあります
一つはカウンセリングでお悩みを聞きます
二つ目は楽しめるバーの提供
みんなで話をしようとかゲームをやろうというもの
3つ目は
外に連れ出そうというサポート
だから私も
ある時は話を聞かせてよと近寄ったり
ある時は旅行や買い物に誘ったりして
なんとか早く元のように笑って仕事に行って欲しくって言っ
努力してきました
朝から大きな声で怒鳴ったりもしました
でも
息子は
と言ったっきり
全く動きませんでした
私は無力感に襲われました
疲れちゃったんです
第何のためにやってきたんだろう
息子のために入っていっ
肩肘張って頑張って頑張って
疲れちゃっ
やっと気づきました
私は息子に勝手な期待をしていたんですよね
前向きに生きてほしい仕事を楽しんでほしい
でも息子は仕事頑張りすぎて苦しくなっ
前が見えなくなってしまっていたんです
私の世間体や立場のためじゃなくてい
息子が何を求めているのか
それを最初に考える必要があったんですよね
[音楽]
そこまでわかるのに
5年かかりました
これまでの3つのサポートに効果がないわけではなくて
私のようにとても時間がかかります
それよりも
何を求めているのか
それを提供することができれば
短期間で社会復帰できるんじゃないのかな
で息子に実際に試してみたら
んなりと動きました
だったら
息子以外の
か守りの人には役に立つんじゃない額が
って考えて活動を始めました
その方法はいたってシンプルです
今のままでもできる仕事をつなぐこと
外に出られなくても人と話をしなくてもできる仕事をやってもらっています
例えば
手書きのアンケートデータ入力する
これだったら連絡もメールでできますし
自宅で十分できます
左側の方は不安障害という心の病気デー
今 excel を教えているもらっているところです
教えているのは脳性まひで車いすを使っている女性です
次の写真は着物をリフォームする方のために塗ってある糸をほどいているところです
この彼女も不安障害です
細かい作業ですけど丁寧にやってくれています
他にも
靴磨き屋
ポスティング
似顔絵やイラストを書く
お庭の草取りや犬の散歩行った作業もあります
作業しだけたとして代金をお支払いします
自分のやった結果で得られるオカメ
自分の力で稼いだお金 a
これは何よりも自信を生みます
私たちは
悩みを聞きません
なぜだと思いますか
悩みを解決するよりも
小さなことでもいいから行動すること
現実を少しでも変えること
厳選しています
家の中や一人で簡単にできる
今のままでもできる仕事
これなんです
この方法のさらに面白いところはここからです
彼らは自分からどんどん変化していくんです
例えばこんなことがありました
ポスティングやホームページの英訳お願いしていた男性は
そろそろ務めにてたいっ
と自分から言ってん
今は私の ca の会社で
by 通しています
仕事から帰ってくると体力をつけるといってランニングを始めたんですよって
お母さんから
内緒で聞きました
別のケースでは統合失調症という病気を持ちながら
ポスティングの仕事を始めた男性の妹さんから
hina さん
うちの兄とすれ違った時にお疲れて手を振ってきたんですよ
こんなこと何十年ぶりだったかな
という声をいただきました
この男性の今が就職をして
憧れだった一人暮らしをしています
みんな自分か
動き始めているんです
引きこもりの人って
本当に働く気があるのって a
思いませんか
私もよく聞かれます
もし位
意欲がないとするなら聞き小森は彼らが望んだ状態なので
幸せな顔をしているはずですよね
でも
そんな顔はしていません
口ではもう仕事をしたくないと言っていても本当は
誰かの役に立ちたい
という想いを心の奥に持っています
私は
その役に立ちたいという思いを彼らが持っていることを
信じています
こういう仕事ありますよやりませんか
で話をするんですが早い人でその時に
やりますと返事がきます
慎重な形でもに3ヶ月後くらいには
仕事を始めています
本人に会って話ができると
8割の方が仕事を始めています
でも
そんな彼らの役に立ちたいという思いを
邪魔するものがあるんですよね
それは
引きこもり
引きこもりというと怠けてる
甘えている
働く気がない
というイメージじゃないですか
では
家にいてー
人とあんまり話もしないけど
家で仕事をする人のことを皆さん
何と呼びますか
痛くワーカー
って呼びますよねー
在宅ワーカー
いかがでしょうか
なんか可能性感じませんか
今まで彼らに付けられていた名前は引きこもり
それを在宅ワーカーと帰ると彼らの役に立ちたいという思いにぴったり合った呼び方に
なります
そう呼ぶことで私たちも
彼らを仕事ができる人と捉えられるようにもなりますよね
だから
これからは引きこもりではなくて在宅ワーカー
という彼らを選んでみませんか
そして今のままでもできる仕事
彼らに頼んでみませんか
私の息子も
スミガキの仕事をやり始めました
今では在宅ワークを始めようという人たちのお兄さん役としてお世話をしています
私もこの活動を始めてから
親子の会話が増えてきました
これが一番嬉しかったかも
私は
これまでタッグさんの引きこもりと呼ばれてきた在宅ワーカーに会ってきました
彼らが一歩を踏み出すとき
そこには共通するポイントがありました
それは
周りの方の意識が変わった時です
もしも
引きこもりという問題を解決したいなら
十分苦しんでいる彼らに変わらせるんじゃないんです
変わるのは
あってほしいと願う
私たちなんです
ありがとうございましたあ